Así que, imagínense lo que es ser joven en la actualidad,
necesitar un trabajo, buscando ganarse la vida,
listos para construir un futuro,
y las oportunidades escasean.
Los jóvenes también me cuentan
que les preocupa no estar aprendiendo las habilidades que necesitan.
Y de nuevo, están en lo cierto.
Nos vemos envueltos en un momento a nivel mundial
en el que el mundo cambia rápidamente en lo laboral.
Estamos en la 4ta revolución industrial.
Los jóvenes no quieren vivir en el campo y en comunidades rurales.
Quieren vivir en las ciudades.
Quieren aprender habilidades del futuro para trabajos del futuro.
Quieren aprender acerca de tecnologías digitales y ecológicas.
Quieren una oportunidad para aprender acerca de agricultura moderna.
Quieren aprender de negocios y el mundo empresarial,
para poder crear negocios propios.
Quieren ser enfermeros, radiólogos farmacéuticas y doctoras.
Quieren contar con todas las habilidades que necesitarán para el futuro.
También deberán aprender oficios, para ser constructores y electricistas.
Estas son las profesiones que un país necesita,
tanto como las profesiones que todavía no se han inventado.
Los jóvenes también me cuentan que les preocupa la violencia.
En casa, en Internet, en la escuela y en sus comunidades.
Y nuevamente, tienen razón.
Un joven puede llegar a tener cientos de amigos en las redes sociales,
pero cuando necesitan un rostro amigable,
alguien que pueda apoyarlos como amigos, con quien conversar,
no tienen a nadie.
Enfrentan «bullying», acoso y más.
Y cientos de millones son sometidos a explotación
y abuso, y violencia.
Cada siete minutos, un niño o niña adolescente
es asesinado en un acto de violencia en alguna parte del mundo.
Y las niñas me cuentan
que están particularmente preocupadas por su futuro.
Y, lamentablemente, están en lo cierto.
Las niñas enfrentan prejuicios y discriminación.
Enfrentan matrimonio infantil
y embarazos prematuros que ponen en riesgo sus vidas.
Piensen en el total de la población de EE. UU.
Ahora duplíquenla por dos.
Ese es el total de mujeres que fueron casadas antes de cumplir 18 años.
Seiscientos cincuenta millones.
Y muchas fueron madres mientras ellas mismas seguían siendo niñas.
Una de cada tres mujeres deberá afrontar violencia física,
o abuso sexual en su vida.
Así que, no es extraño que las niñas estén preocupadas por su futuro.
Estas crisis urgentes pueden no ser una realidad en su vida o en su barrio.
Y quizás tuvieron la oportunidad de una buena educación,
de habilidades útiles y de conseguir empleo.
Y quizás, nunca enfrentaron la violencia, el prejuicio, o la discriminación.
Pero hay decenas de millones de jóvenes que no tuvieron esa suerte.
Y nos están alertando sobre su futuro.
Es por eso que UNICEF y muchos de nuestros socios públicos y privados
lanzamos una nueva iniciativa global.
Los mismos jóvenes la nombraron.
Se llama «Generación sin límites»,
o en inglés, Gen-U o Gen tú.
Lo que nos están diciendo es que es nuestro momento, nuestro turno,
nuestro futuro.
Nuestro objetivo es muy claro.
Queremos a todos los jóvenes en la escuela, aprendiendo, capacitándose,
o en empleos acordes con su edad para el año 2030.
Este objetivo es urgente, es necesario, es ambicioso.
Pero también pensamos que es realizable.
Así que convocamos soluciones innovadoras
y nuevas ideas.
Ideas que les den a los jóvenes la oportunidad de luchar por su futuro.
No conocemos todas las respuestas,
así que estamos pidiendo ayuda a las empresas, los gobiernos, las ONG,
el ámbito académico, las comunidades, y los innovadores.
Generación sin límites es una plataforma abierta,
donde la gente puede compartir sus ideas y soluciones
acerca de lo que funciona, lo que no funciona,
y aún más importante: lo que podría funcionar.
Entonces, si tomamos estas ideas y sumamos un capital inicial,
y buenos socios,
y buena voluntad política,
creemos que pueden crecer y llegar a miles y millones de personas
en todo el mundo.
Con este proyecto, también vamos a hacer algo nuevo.
Vamos a co-diseñar y co-crear con los jóvenes.
Con Generación sin límites van a estar atrás del volante,
marcándonos el camino.
En Argentina tenemos un programa en el que conectamos a los estudiantes
que se encuentran en comunidades remotas o montañosas de difícil acceso,
con algo que ven muy raramente:
un maestro de escuela secundaria.
Entonces los estudiantes en un salón, con un maestro rural de la comunidad
se conectan con escuelas urbanas a través de Internet.
Allí tendrán el maestro de secundaria,
que les enseña acerca de tecnología digital
ofreciéndoles una educación secundaria de calidad
sin que tengan que viajar fuera de sus propias comunidades.
En Sudáfrica, existe un programa llamado Chicas Tecno.
Y estas son chicas que vienen de barrios bajos
pero están aprendiendo disciplinas CTIM:
ciencia, tecnología, ingeniería y matemáticas.
Y tienen la oportunidad de observar profesionales.
De esta forma, pueden verse a ellas mismas
en carreras de ingeniería,
ciencia, y hasta quizás en programas espaciales.
En Bangladesh,
contamos con socios capacitando a decenas de miles de jóvenes
en oficios,
para que puedan ser técnicos en reparación de motocicletas,
o técnicos en telefonía celular.
Esto les da la posibilidad de valerse por sus propios medios.
Y quizás de desarrollar su propio negocio.
Y en Vietnam,
tenemos un programa en el que reunimos a los jóvenes emprendedores
con las necesidades de sus propias comunidades locales.
Entonces con este programa, se reunió un grupo
y decidieron que resolverían el problema del transporte
para personas discapacitadas en sus comunidades.
Y con un mentor y poco de capital inicial,
desarrollaron una aplicación para ayudar a toda la comunidad.
He visto cómo estos programas pueden hacer una diferencia.
Cuando estuve en el Líbano, visité un programa llamado «Girls Got IT»,
o «Chicas en tecnología».
En este programa, las niñas que estudian
informática y el programa CTIM
tienen la oportunidad de trabajar junto a jóvenes profesionales,
para que puedan aprender de primera mano
qué es ser una arquitecta, diseñadora, o científica.
Y cuando vemos a estas niñas, la sonrisa en sus rostros,
el entusiasmo en sus miradas,
están emocionadas, tienen esperanza para el futuro.
Quieren cambiar el mundo.
Y ahora, con este programa con estos mentores,
podrán hacerlo.
Sin embargo estas ideas y programas son solo el comienzo.
Solo llegarán a una porción de los jóvenes que lo necesitan.
Queremos tomar estas ideas y encontrar formas de ampliarlas.
Para llegar a más jóvenes en más comunidades,
y más lugares alrededor del mundo.
Queremos soñar en grande.
¿Sería posible que todas las escuelas en el mundo,
sin importar qué tan remotas,
o inclusive en campos de refugiados,
estén conectadas a Internet?
¿Podríamos tener traducción instantánea para los jóvenes,
para que puedan tener una buena educación
en su propio idioma, en cualquier parte del mundo?
¿Y, sería posible
poder conectar la educación en tu escuela
con las habilidades que necesitarás para tener empleo en tu comunidad?
Para poder transicionar de la escuela al trabajo.
Y más.
¿Puede cada uno de nosotros ayudar?
En nuestra vida cotidiana en nuestros lugares de trabajo,
¿qué podemos hacer para respaldar a los jóvenes?
Los jóvenes nos piden formación,
pasantías, prácticas laborales.
¿Podríamos hacerlo?
Los jóvenes también nos piden programas académicos de empleo.
lugares donde puedan aprender y ganar el sustento.
¿Podríamos hacer esto y conectarnos con las comunidades cercanas,
las menos afortunadas y ayudarlos?
Los jóvenes también quieren ayudar a otros jóvenes.
Quieren más espacio y más voz y voto
para reunirse y ayudarse unos a otros.
En centros de HIV, en campos de refugiados,
pero también para detener el «bullying» y el matrimonio infantil.
Necesitamos ideas, grandes y pequeñas,
ideas a escala local y a escala global.
Al fin de cuentas, esta es nuestra responsabilidad.
Una generación masiva de jóvenes está a punto de heredar el mundo.
Es nuestro deber dejarles un legado de esperanza y oportunidades.
para ellos, pero también con ellos.
Los jóvenes representan el 25% de nuestra población.
Pero son el 100% de nuestro futuro.
Y nos están desafiando por una oportunidad de lucha
para construir un mundo mejor.
Y su desafío también debería ser nuestro.
El desafío de nuestra era.
Y el momento es ahora, la necesidad es urgente.
Y 1.800 millones de niños y niñas jóvenes están esperando.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)